identifica las unidades más razonables
para medir el peso de cada una de las
opciones de bajo cada opción debe estar
situada en una categoría y bueno date
cuenta que aquí tenemos un adulto
promedio una rebanada de pan una mesa de
la cocina y un paquete de chicles y
bueno cada una de estas cuatro cosas las
tengo que asociar aquí con una unidad de
medida de peso lo vamos a medir o en
kilogramos o en gramos y bueno yo soy un
adulto promedio y más o menos peso cerca
de 74 kilos por lo tanto creo que los
kilogramos son bastante buenos para
medir el peso de un adulto así que vamos
a poner este justo en esta categoría el
peso de un adulto lo vamos a medir en
kilogramos
bien ahora cambiemos de color tengo una
rebanada de pan y bueno a menos que sea
una rebanada de pan enorme que se pueda
medir en kilogramos la mayoría de las
rebanadas de pan las podemos medir de
una manera muy sencilla en gramos por lo
tanto yo creo que voy a asociar esta
esta rebanada de pan con los gramos la
voy a asociar con los gramos porque así
va a ser mucho más fácil medir esta
rebanada de pan
ok cambiemos de color y ahora tengo una
mesa de la cocina una mesa de la cocina
bueno esta puede pesar casi igual o
hasta más que un adulto promedio si es
una mesa muy grande por lo tanto voy a
ponerla en kilogramos porque estas las
mesas de las cocinas es mucho más fácil
medir las en kilogramos y bueno
cambiamos de color y por último tengo un
paquete de chicles pero recuerda un
paquete de chicles un paquete de chicles
es bastante ligero por lo tanto yo creo
que lo vamos a medir en gramos si alguna
vez ha sido un gimnasio seguramente
puede recordar que un kilogramo pesa
mucho
que un paquete de chicles por lo tanto
es mucho mejor medir el peso de este
paquete de chicles en gramos que
utilizar los enormes kilogramos y ya
está